FALSEHOODS.
>> AT THE CENTER OF THIS IS THIS
NEW GRAIL THAT WE HAVE.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO TAKE THIS
GUY DOWN?
>> LET'S PUT PART ON SCREEN.
THE MEDIA STRATEGY IS TO SHOW
TRUMP AS A CRAZY SOCIOPATH.
THE TRUMP STRATEGY IS TO SHOW
THE MEDIA ARE PRICKS AND OUT OF
TOUCH.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE.
DO YOU FEEL THAT MY STYLE IS
WRONG OR MY SUBSTANCE IS WRONG
TRYING TO FACT CHECK THE
PRESIDENT?
>> I MEAN THIS WITH TRULY NO
DISRESPECT, BUT I THINK YOU CAN
BORDER ON BEING SORT OF QUITE A
RIDICULOUS FIGURE.
IT'S NOT A GOOD LOOK TO
REPEATEDLY AND SELF-RIGHTEOUSLY
DEFEND YOUR OWN SELF-INTEREST.
THE MEDIA SHOULD NOT BE THE
STORY.
EVERY WEEK IN THIS RELIGIOUS
SENSE YOU MAKE IT THE STORY.
WE ARE NOT THE STORY.
>> THERE'S ROOM FOR ONE HOUR ON
CNN FOR THIS?
>> I LOVE YOUR SHOW.
I WISH YOU WOULDN'T TURN TO THE
CAMERA AND LECTURE AMERICA ABOUT
THE VIRTUES OF THE MEDIA AND
EVERY ONE TRYING TO ATTACK IT.
THE MEDIA WILL BE FINE.
>> THE MEDIA DOESN'T NEED
DEFENDING?
>> THE MEDIA DOESN'T IMMENEED
DEFENDING BY THE MEDIA.
THE NEW YORK TIMES FRONT PAGE
LOOKS LIKE IT'S 1938 IN GERMANY
EVERY DAY.
>> NO IT DOES NOT.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> THE NEW YORKER HAS LEFT ALL
OF ITS STANDARDS B